how do we feed 7 billion
people what about 9
billion how about
14 is there any way that we could do
this
sustainably what would truly sustainable
agriculture look
[Music]
like imagine that this Urban Greenhouse
is your local supermarket when you look
inside rather than seeing rows of a
single crop you find a food producing
ecosystem with fish swimming through
channels and mush rooms growing
underneath fruit
trees this is polydome our vision for
how agriculture could be made more
productive socially Equitable and truly
sustainable at accept integrated
sustainability it is our company Mission
to create the foundations for a
sustainable future agriculture is one of
our key priority areas today's
agroindustrial food production is
focused on single product systems these
monocultures generate far-reaching
problems their structural need for
complex logistical chain siphons money
away from food producers and alienates
consumers from the source of their food
monocultures also concentrate and
separate material flows that would
normally cycle between multiple
ecosystem elements a team of us at
accept came together to develop a smart
polyculture based solution that would
address all of these problems with
support from Dutch partner organizations
Innovation Network and SN we set off on
a year-long research trajectory we
visited Farms interviewed experts and
developed databases on over 400
agricultural products with this
knowledge we created a process for
Designing highly productive Greenhouse
ecosystems we co-located crops and
animals based on their resource
preferences we layered hydroponic
production with soil-based crops we
envisioned internal Logistics systems to
simplify Harvest and processing and we
beneficially coupled material flows
between products polydome can produce
high value Niche products for local sale
rather than growing a single product for
low margin export this can improve the
livelihoods of workers farmers and local
consumers polydom inre Ines food
security and access while improving the
business case for urban
agriculture we published the results of
our work in a free open-source research
document for anyone to use we want
polydome to become a reality and are now
developing Partnerships to build the
first pilot do you share our vision of a
diverse distributed agricultural system
that reconnects people with nature come
talk to us visit www. accept. NL
[Music]